good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your path today's message is
listen to your gut over the you Mel
Robbins when I was twenty-two right
after I graduated from Dartmouth I was
so focused on making everyone happy that
I almost chose the worst possible career
for my personality it's not a bad career
it just would have been horrendous for
me I was interested in the environment
so I decided oh you know I'll go get a
law degree and then I'll go work in
Washington and I think maybe I'll work
on environmental policy and I'd probably
end up in some cube farm and everyone
was thrilled with the plan everyone it
turns out but me so here I am I'm
driving a u-haul across country to go to
law school and to get a degree in
environmental law and something started
to gnaw at me and with every single mile
that I drove my thoughts were getting
louder and doubts were starting to pour
in my gut was telling me Mel turn the
damn u-haul around but the problem was
that everything was already in place
right I mean I'm already in the u-haul
the thing is already packed I'm already
10 miles into my drive the tuition had
been paid for the first semester I had
signed a lease I mean I could not undo
these things
isn't that why it's so difficult for you
to make changes in your life because you
think that things can't be undone the
fact is any excuse that you come up with
you can undo tuition can be reimbursed
apartments can be leased Plan B can be
invented so I got up I repack that
u-haul and I drove out of town
I let myself make a u-turn in life if
you ever find your gut battling your
head save yourself the drama I guarantee
you your gut is right guarantee you your
excuses can be an
and I guarantee you you can make a
u-turn in your life right now if you
want to
you should make big decisions with your
heart or your gut and small decisions
with your head here's why your head only
understands a world that currently
exists it's logical it's practical and
it's also needed you don't want to throw
away all rationale throw away all logic
like that keeps you alive - you need it
but if you have a big decision that you
need to make in your life the worst idea
is to make a list of pros and cons and
then try to evaluate them because you're
trying to make a decision with your head
that really should be made with your
heart because it doesn't matter if you
have 10 things on the pro list if
there's one thing on the con that goes
against what you're really feeling in
your heart or your gut you can't do it
your head or your brain only understands
a world that currently exists and that
is a world that is made up by other
people that world was created by others
and is being forced upon you and so if
you're making decisions purely with your
head then you're living in somebody
else's world they went off and created
all these amazing things and created all
these rules for living and now you're
just following them where if you want to
think about things with your heart the
vision the big dream the things that
don't exist yet
that's the thing your brain doesn't
really understand that's not logical
that's not practical it's it doesn't
exist yet but that's what you're trying
to create with your life if you want to
create a life that has already been
lived by somebody else then just follow
that path listen to your head and that's
your safe logical practical thing to do
if you want to create a path a life that
is unique to you you're going to have to
break the mold somewhere you cannot just
live your parents life
your grandparents life the life that
your guidance counselors want you to
live or the rest your family or your
culture all those lives have been lived
before you want to live your life and
that can only be done by doing something
that is different and that's something
that is different is going to be the
powerful thing that comes from here
there has to be an emotional decision to
break free of the rules break free of
the norms break free of what your
parents want you to do and say I'm gonna
go down this scary path that hasn't been
done before and then what you do is you
use your head to figure out the plan if
you start with the head your heart will
never catch up if you start with the
heart the passion the excitement the
love the interest then your brain can
catch up you see I'm gonna go out I'm
gonna go and create a billion
entrepreneurs I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs the head comes in and said
well you know that's not practical
that's not logical either even a billion
entrepreneurs how you gonna track that
how you gonna measure that you know bump
up up up up up all the reasons why it's
not gonna work out which one do I listen
to
it's the heart I'm gonna go out and do
this head help me figure out how to do
it the big goal the big actions have to
come from the heart have to come from
your place of passion and then your head
will help you figure out how to go and
accomplish it not the other way around
so whenever you're in a moment of crisis
whenever you're trying to make a big
decision
whenever you're afraid whatever you're
thinking about some new big thing that
you want to do to break out on your own
path and it's something that's never
been done before that's gonna be
uniquely yours I hope you will have the
courage to listen to your heart and not
your head so the question today today is
I'm curious what is the biggest decision
that you made with your heart when your
head said no way that's impossible let
me know leaving the comments below I
think sharing it will be great for you
to release and feel the joy of sharing
it but I think also can inspire a lot of
people who are we'd in the comments and
following along as well so leave it down
the comments I also want to give a quick
shout out to Michelle a bark doll
Michelle thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book through one word it
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I hope
you have an amazing day I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
more espresso give me go
recently I was with a bunch of other
investors who I respect and they brought
me a deal and I wanted to be part of it
but it didn't feel right and I wrote
millions of dollars on that one and it
just didn't feel right and I lost it all
within two years
so should investors Trust never got
better absolutely and trust you well
what about you said earlier don't be
emotional and sometimes the gut know
this this is a barometer of risk it's
something an internalized for an
investor that says I don't feel
comfortable
it's not about emotions just don't write
that check that was recently the first
time I didn't listen to that and I lost
everything so now my radar is up I
listen to my gut it's not an emotion
it's an index of risk and you get it as
you age you become a better investor
every year if only I could live to 200
I'd be really good there was a lot of
encouragement to trust my my instincts
you know the instincts of use your
presence you know I'm saying like in
South Africa you know um you know
obviously I'm not South African so I was
really aware that are cut I don't walk
into rooms where people have been lived
seen smell touched felt mr. Mandela in
person on radio and television and here
I come as an outsider doing this him you
know portrayal of him I was really a
ways to make me very nervous about you
know if I'm gonna do it right or not and
Justin encouraged me to stay with what
my gut was hmm is to stay with that
don't don't waver from it don't try to
be there Mandela or Demand oh they think
you should be be that guy we've
discussed in all the rehearsals and all
the script meetings you know be that guy
go with that thing so that was great
actually at Justin's credit like he
really helped me sculpt and measure out
that that performance you know when I
went to blowing deals for the buyer said
we like your tires Ralph but would you
make them narrower and would you we
don't want to use your label we want to
use our own
but we'll give you a really good order
now here I was no business and hungry
and I said to the buyer I said my
heart's in my throat or whatever the
expression is I I would love to sell
Bloomingdale's they were the hottest
store and young hot store I said but I
can't tell you I'm closing my bag and
I'm not going to sell you six months
later they called me back Wow and they
said Ralph we can't find your tights
anywhere and we want to buy him and we
want to put a rack in rack up ties
amongst the other ties and that was it
the breakthrough was they bought it and
the breakthrough for me is that I've
learned to trust my instincts I learned
to trust my own sense but normal thing
to do is say I'll make it with me what
you want there I mean that's how that's
how the world was you want to I want to
sell the other ties you know maybe I'll
have a new fashion for you next year let
me buy it my philosophy was that I love
these times I made them they were not
just a business to me they were they
were my voice to myself if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details